yo man scaredy I wish I prioritized my
health I could have slept one hour left
I could have worked some crazy one I
could have worked one less hour I could
have done a whole lot of things but I
should have found that one hour to do
what I've been doing for the last 65
days and prioritize my health you know I
knew that what I was doing in business
what I was doing in friendship what I
was doing in parenting like that was all
on point but in the back of my mind I
knew that my health wasn't there right
but the way I was rolling I should have
looked a thousand times worse than I
looked back then right like my weight
and just my body structure my natural
DNA kept it in check enough that I
wasn't 400 pounds because there was no
good eating habits there was no running
basically there was zero exercises zero
to the time I was 38 and a half when I
did this so it's on the back of my mind
since I turned thirty crush it came out
in 2009 I was 34 like you know like it's
been there right it's been there it's
been there and then I'm on a flight I'm
just sitting in the plane head against
the window again it pops in my mind
randomly I'm like I really need to get
my [ __ ] together at 30 is when I said
you know I've got to change my business
I'm doing it well but if I really want
to buy the Jets or really accomplished
crazy things I have to make a huge turn
and on my 30th birthday I made that turn
mentally literally my 30th birthday I
was driving to the store I look myself
in the rearview mirror and I said you're
full of [ __ ] your mouth is ahead of your
actions you ain't buying the Jets you're
not gonna buy a jet you can't buy a jet
airplane like get your [ __ ] together and
that's literally when I decided to start
Wine Library TV and go into the web 2.0
thing hello everyone and welcome to the
first episode of while re TV today we
are going to explore the wine library
wine room temperature control lots of
buzz 3,000 square feet and exchange my
life right and so I said you know what
I'm going to do the health version of
that on my 40th birthday
or I even landed so somewhere within
three hours the conversation with myself
went from the hell am I going to wait
244 I'm gonna do this at 39 and then I
said wait a minute like why am I gonna
wait to November this was like March
right I go let's do it now you got to
make the mental switch in the same way
the two years ago I said I'm gonna make
the best look at it just making that
switch of going all in not doing tactics
when you have to be rock has you been
working out yeah my said no because
you're not unless you completely go
black and like you agree with me that is
a mental switch or not they tap it so
slowly you're going to do this it's
binary either you're mentally in the
place of it I think that seriously or
you're not yeah life does whatever it's
going to do just kind of decide what
you're going to do around so and that
happens with an exercise - I think so
yeah just go with it you don't wonder
you know I figured out my health by
tricking myself into a system where I
was accountable to somebody else I
genuinely believe this is a binary game
either you keep yourself accountable or
you're going to be accountable to
somebody else I think a lot of people
that struggle with fitness and health
and fitness and really probably in life
in general in different disciplines is
they're unable to be accountable to
themselves I figured out that I needed a
full-time health person that was not my
full-time trainer that was my full-time
health person meaning they've only
worked for me period end of story and I
would make that big financial commitment
and then I would be accountable to that
person so I call Mike I said can you
know somebody and he said what I would
do when I go whoa you're going to give
up all your other stuff he's like yeah
it's worth it
there's something he doesn't know that
I'm going to tell him because it's our
last workout ever
is that I'm working out with you today
any trouble a smoke out ever Georgia
tomorrow and and the tape oh I don't
even know that yeah I just got that
yeah I've been said I'm now you know two
and a half three years in like dinner
for two years now with Jordan he'll do
it for three years he's six month in but
when you have taken over with Jerry what
has been your main focus we've actually
gone through a bunch of different
focuses throughout the main thing number
one was helping him feel really good
that was from day ones and out the most
important thing is to make sure he feels
really get it no pain so we've improved
his talk to soft tissue quality all over
especially in his hips and his legs and
then now also an addition that just want
to stack off the muscle the next couple
months before we do start a little bit
of a summertime it's been changing I'm
much more athletic and nimble I've been
really chopping away and like my
inefficiencies I work out seven days a
week seven I am in the gym every you
know and one day maybe a stretch or
things entry but but nonetheless like it
does not come natural to me let's do not
come natural to me there's fat Gary
quino's cut it in right now hockey rock
there's a right way to get a six-pack
for your stomach
there's exercises right and there's a
diet I know what they are
I'm not doing it
you know I tell a lot of my creative
friends I'm like you need to find a
business partner yeah game somebody ten
there's so many people out there
marketing [ __ ]
yeah go find one of those people and let
the market your great stuff yeah and
give up 10 to 50 percent if it takes
that much because at the end of the day
if you're trying to make it a living in
the business and if you don't know how
to run a business or if you don't know
what to do oftentimes it doesn't work
out but most of all I'm just I feel good
about the long term I know when I'm 50
60 70 80 90 I'm going to be in a better
position had I had actually been if I
had not done that I'm going to lose 15
pounds muscles everybody rocks and
Matthew me sure with keynote
[Music]
like basketball
[Music]
of course is supposed to be hard
people Gary it's so hard no [ __ ] [ __ ]
are you willing to pay the price for
what you want you want a 1% light but
you're not willing to put in a 1% work
ethic let's people fill of all time why
should that be easy makes no sense
we all think something real takes time
everybody's impatient they're not just a
young 10 thing the world's impatient
when I'm on the York I'm all in one way
you can't be 5050 working out 50 50
units in relationships 50/50 in your
escapism 50/50 in the way you play
that's why everybody's average you've
these macro yin-yang micro all in one
way or the other to make that binary
switch you're like I'm gonna work a lot
I'm not mad excuses anymore I'm going to
be very patient I'm going to learn how
to build a business then things can
happen just like I made a switch here
forever 7 days a week like
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]